okay hi everyone it's a pleasure to be
here
so my titles on training college and
game agents with deep reinforcement
learning and so what can you expect so
if there was a subtitle to talk I would
call it wide deep reinvest reinforcement
learning is so hard to get working
there's a fair bit of maps and hopefully
you've kind of had experience with deep
learning and kind of understand terms
like likelihood stochastic gradient
etcetera and you've had experience
working with any auto grad library even
if you're kind of very kind of new to
machine learning and you should
hopefully be able to kind of get the
intuition about kind of how we train
agents and deep reinforcement learning
yeah so there's a lot to get through and
yeah don't be kind of worried if I you
don't digest everything so just a quick
intro kind of about me so I currently
work in the research and development
team found this Factory I studied my
masters in physics and I'm very kind of
obsessed with deep reinforcement
learning and hopefully I can kind of
convey that kind of passion to you today
so they're kind of outline for this talk
is we're going to talk about we're just
going to have an introduction to what
deep reinforcement learning is Markov
decision processes MVPs are the kind of
backbone behind reinforcement learning
in general and then we've got three kind
of kind of classes of methods main
classes of methods used in reinforcement
learning policy gradients value based
methods and active critics doll methods
and then we'll kind of conclude after
that and so kind of just to start off
like it's a good idea to you see kind of
where reinforcement learning fits in to
into machine learning so supervised
learning is very much about kind of
building model that
data t labels and you've got a very
well-defined task unsupervised learning
is a kind of bit more broader and it's
usually kind of involves kind of kind of
fundamentally understanding their kind
of structure or probability distribution
of your data and kind of lots of kind of
techniques like clustering
dimensionality reduction density
estimation generating new samples our
fit into unsupervised learning and
reinforcement learning is about
maximizing the rewards we get from the
environment so it's it's not entirely
supervised learning it's not entirely
unsupervised learning it's kind of how
it fits you know in its own kind of
domain because so the main task is that
we're trying to kind of maximize whether
we're trying to learn a behavior or a
policy in the environment that we're in
and we don't so into buys learning
you've really got the data to start off
with you've really got your labels but
what we actually interact in the
environment and then we get data so and
how we kind of choose to interact with
environment kind of changes what a data
we've got we get and that kind of
changes how we then and so a good
example is kind of like when you've got
a toddler you know who kind of kind of
approaches a fire or flame for the first
time and they're not going to do it
again and because they've learnt that
that action corresponds to some negative
reward so other things which we will
kind of see later is that the feedback
can be delayed and we usually have a
goal in mind but we don't necessarily
have to and yes so we don't have labels
per se we have the reward signals and so
here's kind of
a few kind of kind of objective a few
kind of typical machine learning tasks
and kind of let's kind of discuss about
where they fall in so kind of things
like detecting tumors from MRI scans I
think you know it's pretty clear that
it's you're using supervised learning
because you you need to have labels of
you know you need to have positive and
negative labels in order to learn what's
what's two more isn't compression so
there's no labels in that so it's
unsupervised something like predicting
house prices you know you'd probably
have kind of labels like you know
distance to a station and other kind of
things which will affect a house price
and then you'd kind of build a function
approximately that kind of maximizes
that kind of likelihood of kind of
getting the right kind of house prices
so fake news generator that's a bit of a
kind of it's a weird one so usually for
language models we're kind of so
language models like faking a generator
is it's unsupervised because you haven't
got any true labels you're learning
you're learning the kind of probability
you you're maximizing likelihood that
your tokens your words your sentences
come from your data the way you train it
is very akin to supervised learning so
like if you've kind of seen how like a
text generators trained its trained like
using like an auto regressive models
where you you've got your kind of
probability distribution of all your
tokens and then you can of fact write
out and the label is your next token so
you're maximizing for example like the
probability of token 10 given token 0 to
9 or 1 to 9
yep yes so I know totally negative walk
so that doesn't really fit in to
unsupervised learning and because you're
kind of learning kind of kind of really
you're trying to maximize your kind of
reward in your environment but it's not
supervised learning as well because you
don't have the labels to start off with
we kind of interact with your
environment the table kind of changes
how they move etc to kind of learn kind
of what's how to walk and how not to
walk okay so I'll go through this
quickly so here's some examples of
reinforcement learning and so the first
one top left is the kind of is the kind
of nature article about alphago and I
think that was one of the kind of first
kind of bigfeetz
in reinforcement learning you've got a
typical typically kind of robotics you
would try to use kind of reinforcement
learning for example to to pick up an
object so you would have rewards for
example where you have negative one
reward everywhere and but you have a
large positive reward once the hand
reaches the object and you've got
personalized ad recommendations that's
an example of reinforcement learning
self-driving cars and sometimes you can
train a machine translation using
reinforcement learning C up so deep
reinforcement ending is literally kind
of deep learning philosophy enforcement
learning so you have you have your kind
of an environment where so say you're
trying to kind of solve a Rubik's Cube
you take an action so that's something
you can control and your action is kind
of governed by your policy that's what
we're trying to learn
and so given the particular
configuration we're trying to learn an
action that maximizes the total reward
which renlund a policy that maximizes
and total reward and so you have your
Rubik's Cube you take an action and then
you end up with a different
configuration of your Rubik's Cube so
that's the next day and you also kind of
get a reward whether you're that could
be for example with you or whether
you've got for example one side and all
the same color etc and your goal is to
kind of kind of have a policy or kind of
a set of actions which maximize your
expected reward and that can be kind of
defined as kind of maximizing theta so
our policy is kind of parametrized by
theta and that might size its expected
reward and so that's probability
directory and I've just kind of flag
dries it out okay so I'll talk about
this kind of briefly so MDP kind of
gives us a kind of formulation of how an
agent kind of can interact in this
environment and it's the backbone and of
RL so usually in MVP you have you're in
a particular state and you can choose an
action and you get to another state and
sometimes you choose your on one state
and you choose an action and you get to
one particular state but then next time
you pass by that state and you choose
the same action you enter a different
state so it's governed by kind of
transition probabilities and the kind of
the kind of key thing about MVPs is that
though they obey the markov property
which is that the probability that you
enter the next state given your current
state is always constant it's
independent of your history and that's
something that kind of you really need
in reinforcement learning for things to
work
yeah so it's basically our sufficient
statistic so I'm a sufficient cystic is
a so for example in a recurrent neural
network your latest hidden state is if
you were kind of using or an end to kind
of model identity then your latest
hidden state would be your and
sufficient cystic and so just to be a
bit more formal so MVP and has a set of
possible states so for example all the
places delivery drone can be a set of
actions so it could be the different
kind of motions like moving forward back
left up right down or kind of staying
stationary the transition probabilities
usually they're deterministic so if you
take if you're in a state and you take
an action you'll usually always end up
in the next state but sometimes in
different environments you they're not
deterministic and you need to kind of
consider transition probabilities kind
of carefully then you have your rewards
so the rewards are usually man-made so
in this case for example you could give
a positive reward when the drone
delivers the package to the right house
or a -10 reward for example if it livers
to if it's doing nothing or it's
delivering it to wrong house oh yeah and
sometimes you have states which are
terminal which means that you kind of
stop and your rollout is finished and so
an example would be if a drone crashes
into a tree or if it completes his
mission okay so
okay so I'll just quickly run through
this so usually we don't want to
calculate the exact sum of the rewards
because if you have and if you have like
an infinite trajectory then your rewards
will kind of diverge if you're of all
your rewards are positive and so usually
we apply discount factor usually about
something like no point 999 and set out
the rewards kind of further away are
still relevant furthering to the beach
are so irrelevant but and like their
total reward is still capped yeah and it
also helps us reduce the variance as
well usually we're not usually kind of
we want to talk about the expected kind
of return rather than just a return in a
single rollout so that's the cue
function and the Q function can be just
written out like an expectation under
your policy so the PI here's a denotes
your policy so if you yeah so if you
have a different policy then you're
gonna have a different Q value because
your total rewards are we kind of
different or your return will be
different and that useful no value is an
Adu SFIL kind of function is their value
function and that's similar to a key
function but it's the expected reward
given a particular state you're in
so yeah we want to find a policy that
visits optimal value states or we want
to equivalently you should convince
yourself that it's the same we want to
kind of have a policy that kind of
always chooses the states that give us
the maximum return so we label them as Q
star so Q star is the optimal action
value okay okay so were you mentioned
that just a quick side note so usually
in the real world we're working with
partially observable MDPs and there MDP
is that don't obey the Markov property a
good example would be for example if you
saw if you had a at this state if you
had a state of a picture of the car and
then you know where its location is that
for example you don't know whether it's
driving right or left or backwards or
forward you don't know it's acceleration
usually kind of for in order to turn a
harshly observable MDP into an MDP we
take into account its previous states as
well
stuff for example if you know where the
car was like in the last and few seconds
then you can work out its velocity
acceleration and everything you need to
know so the first kind of reinforcement
learning method we see is policy
gradient method so it's called reinforce
and so remember our objective is to
maximize is to find the policy parameter
theta that maximizes the expected return
in our environment
so we just called J the expected return
usually we kind of use Jane for dokkan
of objective
and so we want to in order to find a
maximum we need to take the grading of
it but it's not so straightforward
because you can't take a grading of
expectations so we use something called
a school function trick or it's also
called a log derivative trick or
reinforce trick and so if you kind of
write the expectation as an integral
then you can take so grad of Pi can be
rewritten as High grad log of Pi and
then we can take the PI out and then
we've got an expectation over an
objective that we can other gradients
that we can compute and the nice thing
about this is that so or when we write
it out when we kind of factorize out the
kind of policy over a trajectory then we
can see that states and transition
dynamics are independent of theta and so
we can kind of get rid of them and so
we're left with this kind of objective
okay all right so so how do we train
this and so we can write the expectation
as just kind of a sum of an average and
and the variance of this is very pie so
one thing one trick we can do is is like
we realize that the future actions don't
don't depend on the past and don't
determine the past rewards so we only
need to find out the rewards to go when
we're at a particular state so this is
the Q function by the way as well and so
that the thing inside of bracket can be
looked at as a cue function when it's in
expectation
okay so so we're computing the maximum
likelihood estimate of our policy so
when we're using like Auto graduals and
we this kind of objective is quite nice
because it means that we can just get
rid of the Grad and just take the loss
as this sorry got loss and so it can be
seen as kind of a product of two parts
so the first part is kind of very
familiar in supervised learning and so
it's basically like a supervised
objective where your actions are kind of
and the labels and your as this your
what kind of data and so if you're
working in the discrete action space
then your maximum your negative
likelihood M is usually computed with a
cross entropy or in the case where it's
continuous you kind of make the kind of
assumption you make the assumption that
probably distribution is Gaussian and
then we do two squared error between
your target and your estimate
and so it's weighted by the return so
what this means is that we're kind of
taking larger steps where you've got
kind of bigger returns okay so in the
first notebook there is a kind of a task
on implementing the policy gradient and
so you might want to like kind of just
take a few minutes to kind of have a
look look at that
okay all right there should have been an
email sent out with github link okay
okay but I want to kind of show it here
as well yep yep
okay one second I think I'll show it in
here instead all right how do you think
that just strike right in there for
hitches all right okay so I'll just show
it quickly over here and sure
oh wait there's somebody all right okay
oops sorry I can't see from here
yep all right so oh yeah so different
zip files so yes so it's lost in Bayes
and then training occlusion game agents
we doing postal enemy and so yeah it's
the first one in policy gradient okay I
think I'll just kind of quickly explain
what's going on here right now so we're
using the opening eyes gym environment
and so so with the environment we can
kind of do kind of rollouts in we can do
rollouts and get the state actions and
rewards as we're going along and so over
here we kind of build a policy Network I
tried to start with TF layers dense
intensive level 1.13 and for some reason
it was ten times slower to do the
forward pass I'm not sure why and so
here we're computing the policy
as a function of our sinks so the size
of that should be kind of the number of
actions which is - and over here we kind
of so our objective is here so it's kind
of the mean of the log policy actions
times they're kind of rewards to go yeah
sure okay that's what about and over
here I've added and so you can ignore
you don't need to worry about this part
too much but and I've added an entropy
term because it helps with kind of
exploration and making sure it doesn't
kind of the policy doesn't converge too
quickly
okay and yeah so you kind of compute
that loss and then you kind of update
your network and then you continue to do
rollouts
and then kind of so in here to carpool
it's the aim of the game is to kind of
get it to balance and so it did that
okay so I'll just go back to the reward
does everyone have access to this link
okay I'm going to try to get back to the
PowerPoint now one second
all right yeah
okay
so kind of unfortunately kind of the
algorithm we're using is quite poor
because the grading of the variants of
the gradients are quite large and so
kind of what I did to kind of show is
and I kind of compared to kind of
gradient methods once called one the one
we're using is reinforced and other ones
called repair motorisation trick we
can't use a rebound terrorization trick
and because our we can't arrow we can't
differentiate our rewards respect to
kind of our policy parameters but I put
it yeah
so it's a kind of a weird objective but
you can think of it as like a fixed like
VA with a fixed decoder and ignoring the
KL divergence term so we're trying to
find we're trying to find the encode the
parameters that maximizes dis likelihood
and both P and Q are Gaussian
distributions and Beck hues mean and
standard deviation are parameterize by a
neural network so all this skip this
part and okay so so the black so you can
ignore the green dot the black dot is
the kind of destination of of where
durand crosses or us to go that's when
the cross is kind of converged to the
black dot and we've kind of maximized
our likelihood and so you can see that's
it kind of actually you can't actually
see this on the screen and but there's
supposed to be like a disk showing the
standard deviation and that's like the
points are all kind of all over the
place so if you look at the means here
the kind of true meaning is kind of 5:5
that's the point it's supposed to
converge to but it's actually sort of
the cross is where the mean where the
mean of our prediction is it actually
kind of just kind of ambles around it
and kind of bounces kind of back and
forth and then kind of eventually kind
of gets there but it's still taking huge
strides
and kind of if you have an allowing or a
lower learning rate than this then it
just blows up and you get land values in
contrast with the kind of pathways
derivative or the reformation trick and
you find that it kind of nicely slowly
goes towards the right direction towards
a black dot yeah so I just interrupted
it now
okay so we're back to where we are
there's a very good paper which kind of
kind of kind of explains how to take
kind of ingredients through kind of
Monte Carlo kind of estimates it's
called gradient estimation using
stochastic computational graphs and it's
by a schlingman at walk it out okay so
can we train this on old data and so
when we're kind of kind of collecting
new data is collecting new data is very
expensive and so sometimes you might
want to kind of reuse our old data and
but if we look at this objective it says
that the trajectory or the kind of our
kind of state selection samples kind of
have to be in the kind of current policy
that we're in so that's why it's called
policy gradient because it's on policy
you can you can derive a kind of off
policy version but it's really nasty and
so you can use something called
important something which is usually
used for when you want to kind of reduce
the variance of an expectation so in
this case so in this case kind of PI bar
would be our kind of policy under a new
trajectory sorry M would be all kind of
new policy another new new parameters
and an approximation to this gives us
this really horrible kind of objective
and the kind of really bad thing about
this is that so this term over here is
kind of exponential in your time and so
it can blow up or kind of go to zero and
so kind of using a baseline can also
help you kind of reduce the variance of
your gradients and so you can the way
you can show this is by taking the
expectation of the grad log of your
policy times B and showing that equals
to zero and now you might be wondering
like why we you might want to do this
well if you take and so if you take the
if you can't play the variance of this
by taking the expectation minus the
expectation s squared then you will kind
of find that the variance kind of can
decrease with a good baseline and a good
baseline is typically an average reward
and we'll come back to that later so the
kind of pros and cons or policy gradient
is that sort of one big Pro is that you
can learn stochastic policies and and
the reason why that's good is like for
example if you've got a game of
rock-paper-scissors
then if you've if you have a
deterministic policy then like an
opponent can easily exploit that by kind
of for example if you've if you always
kind of decide to do and kind of
scissors and after your opponent is
rocked and they're polling that can
exploit that and kind of always win and
we'll see kind of a good example in just
a bit and you can work with discrete and
I continuous action spaces and so
generally it's hard to kind of modify
your algorithm to work with continuous
action spaces and that there's kind of
no reason why you can't do both and
because in our objective and it works
fine they're kind of
gradients are unbiased and so it means
that you can kind of converge to a local
optimum and they're kind of on the cons
we've seen that the variance is kind of
very high and we can take some measures
to reduce that like using a larger patch
size or smaller learning rate it's also
not straightforward to kind of implement
it with off policy data and if you've
got an environment that's deterministic
then it learns less quicker than new
terminus new policies okay so one kind
of good example of a game I found and is
so your environment and and each of
these squares is a state that you can be
in and obviously you want to get the the
kind of money back and you want to avoid
their skulls now if you're using a
stochastic if you're using a
deterministic policy so in this
environment and the environment is kind
of is partially observable so the state
doesn't so when the states on one of the
gray spots it doesn't know whether it's
on the left one on the right one because
it seeds a door either way but if you're
learning deterministic policy then you
have to choose one and so you'll kind of
be so if you if you're on the left then
you'll kind of be stuck and in that kind
of loop and you won't get help
but in this stochastic policy and you
would it would probably you you'd have
like an even probability of going left
or right so we looked at policy based
methods and now we're going to look at
value based methods and the question
is coming met the policy gradients
completely and so kind of we return to
our initial objective which is that we
want to visit Q values and remember the
Q values are the the Q's and values are
given a state in action is the kind of
expected reward from that state and so
we want to kind of visit the optimal
ones so we always so when we're out of
state and we've been presented with
different actions we want to go to the Q
that's heist and and so we want to yeah
so we want to take the action basically
that we're we're always in kind of a
little more q states
so obviously normal actions are equal if
we know the optimal action value we've
kind of solved a problem and so we can
land optimal q values directly and so
we'll talk about that in a bit so one
method we can use is something called
bootstrapping and that basically says
that we can kind of get our kind of a
better estimate of the value in our
current state by knowing the kind of
value in the next state and so the
intuition is is that their rewards flow
kind of from the future time Setsu to
present time steps another way of
looking at is that the value estimates
at higher time steps are more reliable
so for example if you if you're kind of
one step and the forward terminal state
then then you've then you've got a much
lower variance because there's only a
few actions that you can take and
a few rewards you can get that if you're
at the start of your MVP
then there's lots of possibilities that
you can of kind of rewards that you can
get so for finite number of states kind
of the development of the amount the
operators defined as so be and of the
value state is the action that maximizes
your reward plus gamma x so this T here
is that transition dynamics matrix but
you can think of it as an expectation
after kind of next values and it can be
shown - they can be shown that it's a
contracting operator and that basically
means that if we keep applying the
bellman optimality operator
then we can kind of converge to optimal
value States and so it also applies to Q
values - unfortunately when we're using
deep learning we don't have any kind of
guarantees on the convergence and to see
why that's the case is that usually so
we're working in continuous States so we
don't kind of construct the matrix in
typical Q line and what we want to do is
we want to so why here is there kind of
is the target is the target value and so
Y here is basically the maximum of the R
or plus the next value step and we want
to kind of minimize bellmen error and
and so that should be there should be a
beta it should be B operator here and
basically what you can show is that
when you have both of these contractions
together then you don't get a
contraction anymore and but you can
still kind of expect some kind of good
results and this problem is known as the
deadly triad and and if you want to know
more about it you can look in a
pseudonym Otto's book okay so for deep Q
networks we have our Q function as a
reward plus and get my times the maximum
direction that maximizes that the
maximum Q value in the next state and we
want to minimize this error so I put
kind of ice cubes kind of over this
target value this target Q because we
actually don't want to change so we
don't want to back propagate gradients
for our target value because we're using
it as a reference unfortunately we're
not kind of learning a maximum
likelihood estimation anymore and that's
because we're using that's because our
kind of target and why is no longer our
kind of max our kind of target Q value
is isn't accurate it's still an
estimation and yes so the target Q value
is biased and tall yeah and how evil use
and SMA Q values are correlated so kind
of just to understand the problem
instability in acute learning a bit more
we can think of our kind of Q values as
being parameters so we can think of our
Q values as a net and where the net is
kind of where the shape of the net is
kind of parameters by teacher and you
work rameters so when we have high local
key value that's larger than our initial
estimate we update our parameters using
stochastic gradient descent and we
pulled the net higher unfortunately when
we pulled the net higher we also pull
the neighboring points as well and we
might not necessarily want to do that
and so if we upgrade a policy in every
time step we effectively keep and kind
of increasing the net pulling up the net
in the same place so one way to kind of
mitigate this is by kind of randomizing
the kind of state's actions rewards and
that we kind of feed in to our objective
and so this is called a replay buffer so
the replay buffer basically stores your
state action reward and next state to
Falls and then when you want to update
the Q value you take a tuple from random
and that kind of ensures that you're not
picking the kind of the tuples that are
next to each other and this kind of
states that are next to each other and
the actions are next to each the state
action pairs that are next to each other
and so you're not getting that kind of
problem we kind of discussed before it's
really easy to implement and there's no
kind of correction term and so basically
we just kind of and changed they're kind
of the expectation part so now it's our
tuples are coming from the buffer
so that's our objective and okay so
another way we can kind of mitigate the
issue is by decoupling the target
Network parameters from the estimated
queue and so there's kind of two places
where we can get the target parameters
so one is by having a totally new queue
network and so the same queue network
kind of trained on different samples and
so that would kind of help kind of
increase stability or we can use an
usually what's usually used is an older
saved network of our queue values and
the downside to that is that the older
kind of cue values are still somewhat
correlated with the current queue values
sometimes you can use kind of polyak so
yeah so one so one way of kind of
adjusting the network parameters is
using polyak averaging so we're just
slowly updating orthia parameters and so
you can see an example so this diagram
here as well so after every and k number
of steps you kind of transfer your
current and theta to your your target q
theta like if they're choosing an
exploration policy for all outs so when
we kind of run the algorithm we need to
make a kind of decision about kind of
what actions we take and so kind of
initially you might think that you want
to take the actions that maximized Q
value the next Q value and because then
you're more likely to kind of go into
regions with a higher reward but
sometimes
what you might find is that and if you
explore kind of kind of uncharted areas
they might have kind of much higher Q
values and usually kind of a good
exploration policy can be kind of
difference between a really bad
algorithm in a really good algorithm and
so one common one is called epsilon
greedy so with a certain probability you
choose maximum Q back you choose
direction with the maximum Q value
otherwise you kind of choose any other
action at random okay draw some other
kind of exploration kind of heuristics
one common one is called Boltzmann
acceleration we just basically take the
action kind of proportional to the
exponential of the q function off your
different actions okay so that's a kind
of overview of deep Q learning so you
kind of save your target Network
parameters you kind of run a rollout and
you can kind of choose which what policy
you am used to run a rollout and then
use sample some tuples from your replay
buffer and then you kind of train this
loss and so there's different things you
can so you can tweak the algorithm in in
different ways so you can choose to for
example before you can choose for
example to take a loop from say four to
three in a cycle if you wanted to if for
example kind of gathering data is very
expensive
okay another problem in kind of
q-learning is this kind of problem of
overestimating our Q values so usually
and one way I kind of try to minimize
this bellman error or temporal
difference error we're taking away kind
of constantly kind of minimizing this
entire bellman error but actually kind
of what you want is so ideally in like
an ideal world you kind of want so our Q
values are noisy and you want the you
want to take the bellman difference of
the kind of true Q value and of the true
kind of Q values for your target and
current state and so ideally you'd want
to kind of take the kind of expectation
of those Q values but what you're in
fact doing is you're taking an
expectation over the maxes and and that
basically means that you're kind of
overestimating your target Q value okay
so in double Q learning and they kind of
get around that and this kind of issue
of kind of D correlating the noise and
in our kind of actions we take from the
noise and the values and it's by any
kind of a subtle method and they
basically choose a different network to
select action from the from the network
to kind of evaluate the values so that's
our kind of current sorry that's our
current target value and just a one
thing we change is now we kind of take
the odd max
over there kind of over the kind of the
current q-value parameters rather than
their target parameters and that
basically works to kind of be correlate
this noise issue and so in the double
q-learning
paper they found that so I'm sure how
they got their true value and but what
they found was that in double windy kind
of applied a fix
then the value estimates and were kind
of much my career okay so okay so
there's a kind of a notebook 4q loan as
well one second so you might just want
to take a bit of time to kind of look
into that
so it's this one here it's called double
DQ and breakout I think I did the three
later on for my own reference so you
might just want to take a couple of
minutes to kind of the camera
okay so
so I can't play the video so here's my
thing okay so there's kind of a few
things I just want to kind of point out
in here and that is so it's so your
working environment of breakout and now
this is an example this is an example of
partially observable MDP because given
our current state so if you so like this
picture is a state that would be kind of
usually fed in to our MVP now from that
state you don't know whether it's moving
right or left and so it's a partially
observable MVP and the way to the way
usually they forward horror games they
kind of obviate this issue is by
stacking the previous frames as well
so over here you've got four previous
frames that are kind of stacked together
so here
and the other kind of subtlety probably
that you might and I notice is that so
our Q functions a function of our state
and actions but for the network we only
input our state's and we kind of
empowers only our states because we want
to get the Q function for all our
possible actions and so the output of a
network is the Q functions for and for
that particular state and all the
different actions and the reason why we
do it this way is that it's very easy to
do to odd match because then you can
just select the highest Q value and
that'll subtlety with
yet so with normal kind of dqn the
target values are kind of
straightforward to kind of implement and
the only thing you need to do 4wqn is
just get the old max for the other
network and of the kind of current
action values Q values and so here's
another thing as well so we want to so
we use TF dot stop gradient and for our
target values because we don't want to
back propagate through them and actually
in this particular case and the way
itself you don't need to use - you have
don't stop gradients because when you've
got the copy the after network the
gradients can't buy prop grave anyway
okay so all this connects so they're
kind of lost kind of kind of group of
algorithms is called that we're looking
at is actor critic algorithms and so
basically we've looked at policy based
methods and we've looked at value based
methods and we want to know is there a
way of kind of combining both of them
together so with with the policy based
methods we saw that we saw that they
were unbiased but the variance was quite
large and the kind of intuition for why
the variance was so large is because
when you're taking the expected returns
when you are taking the rollouts and you
can have lots of different possible
returns and so you can have for the same
policy you can have one very high return
and one very low return and
but for q values we saw that we found
that they were biased because of
development operator and not that can't
be applied them for deep learning but
and the variance is also the variance
however is very low and the reason for
that is because you're just taking the
mean squared error between your current
Q value and the estimate of your next Q
value and your next Q value won't change
much over your algorithm as you're
training so okay so if you look at kind
of our kind of objective degree in this
we want to take and kind of in place of
Phi we have the kind of expected return
so if we take Phi as just kind of
expected return as a way of kind of
running our policy then we have a policy
gradient algorithm and we can apply a
kind of control variant or baseline to
reduce the variance however this is the
exact same thing as the Q value and so
the reason why I put the Q value over
there as well is because you can
parameterize your Q value with a neural
network and so it will be biased and but
the kind of objective is the thing and
but you'll have lower variance a kind of
a good space line to use is your value
at your current state and so when you
take Q minus V it's called an advantage
and the kind of intuition behind that is
that
your kind of advantage is your so your
advantage a particular state in action
is so if you take a particular it's so a
particular state your advantage is how
much better it's a particular action
compared to any other action and you saw
that sorry and we saw that we can apply
the kind of baseline as long as it's
kind of independent of your actions and
so your expectations won't change yo
sorry the expectation of the gradients
and won't be different but it'll just be
lower the variance of them will be lower
and and so with the advantage they're
written over there as Q minus V and you
can train it using two different neural
networks if you wanted to only use one
neural network then you can just write Q
as your so remember your Q is your Q
value is your kind of door-ward you get
your tape after you take a particular
action and plus they're kind of some of
your awards if you kind of run the
policy and they expected some of the
rewards if you can have run the policy
and and so that's just basically rewards
plus your discount factor times your
next value state and so and this is a
kind of typical kind of algorithm for Q
actor critic so kind of one thing to
kind of point out is that so you've got
two different neural networks and you
need to update Q and C you're updating Q
using the bellman error as well or the
temporal different Sara and and so this
objective is still biased because of
that Q but the variance is greatly
reduced
and and here's one for the the advantage
actor critic and it's basically very
similar except we've taken the we've
taken the advantage to be and so we've
just taken instead of the cue over here
we've just used so on the last line it
says theta you update the kind of theta
using advantage times gradient of log pi
you just changed the cue to your
advantage and so I think yeah so there's
a a notebook for this particular
algorithm and that's the last notebook
on there so you might want to look at
that it's called
yeah advantage activated quit and the
kung-fu gym environment
so there's not much so you're trying to
different neural network so one for your
policy and one for your value and but
other than that there's not much that's
different from the policy gradient
okay
and so kind of I've trained it and so if
you get time you can have a look at it
as well and so it kind of works pretty
well I'm going to go back to the slides
and so let's take a look at one of the
advantage estimates okay okay so if we
look at our advantage estimates again
and so we were using we were trying to
minimize the temporal difference era and
using between by kind of minimizing the
error between the current Q value state
and your next next value state you can
get a lower you can expand your next
value state as your as a reward plus
gamma times the next value state two
steps on and you can keep doing that and
eventually you basically get the policy
gradient and with a baseline which is
your value state and so kind of you the
kind of range from here is that you have
a high bias and low variance at the top
but at the bottom you have a low bias
and high variance so at the top the
reason why so at the bottom the reason
why you have a high variance is because
the rewards from the rewards from your
rollout can have a high variance so
under the same policy you can have lots
of different you can have a kind of a
great range of returns and the reason
why you've got a low variance at the top
is because you're only kind of is only
kind of the kind of variance you get
from your value state in x value state
and you're the kind of reward at the
next when you take an action at that
state
okay so I'll just kind of skip this so
there's okay so kind of one of the more
kind of advanced algorithms is called
DDP g-give deterministic policy gradient
and it looks at their kind of so if we
look at back at the if we look back at
q-learning
we have to take we had to take an odd
max over the Q the Q values and however
if you're working with a continuous
action space then you can't really it's
very difficult to kind of find a way to
take an OGG Max and so the intuition
behind DD PG is that you want to take so
if you so you use a deterministic policy
and and your deterministic policy is
kind of dependent on your state and you
just kind of differentiate your Q values
see you just basically kind of take the
derivative of your deterministic policy
with respect to your and theater from
your Q values and because you want to
kind of take gradient ascent and to kind
of make sure you get a policy that kind
of maximizes and the Q values and
and so the loss is just basically so
you've got to loss so you got your loss
from your critic and which is just
computed with you or bellman error and
then you lost with your actor which and
you can do using chain rule and so it
won't really go into this other
algorithm it's called trust I won't go
too much into it so it's called trust
region policy optimization and basically
it kind of looks at the kind of the
variance the kind of high variance issue
and in usual policy gradient and what it
does is it tries to so they're kind of
intuition behind it is if you've got a
policy and which is parametrized by
theta if you kind of change theta by a
small amount then there's a possibility
you can have a completely different wild
policy especially if it changes you can
especially if it changes the policy at
the especially if it changes the kind of
actions towards the beginning of the
directory and so the kind of solution is
well why don't we constrain the kind of
the policy our new policy from our old
policy and with a KL divergence and I
mean it's constrained and so that it's
less than Delta and it works much much
better than old algorithms we've seen so
far including DDP G and so kind of
loffley I kind of want to talk about why
deep reinforcement learning isn't really
kind of ready to be kind of deployed at
large it's a really hard for a number of
reasons and so classical robotic
techniques kind of in optimal control
outperform RL already
and it's too it's too de a hungry
usually kind of when you're working with
complex environments then you have to
wait a very very long time before you
see your kind of rewards starting to
pick up it also requires a reward
function and that's kind of manmade as
well and so in sometimes there's
environments where it's very difficult
to see kind of how you can kind of
allocate the rewards in the best way and
you can fall into suboptimal behaviors
and I will show one example of that on
the next slide and it's poor at
generalization and transfer learning
it's very sensitive to high perform to
tuning and this can make it really
frustrating because usually you don't
know so if you've built a new algorithm
then you have to wait a very very long
time before you can work out whether
your algorithm is good or not because
for for a long time you're just going to
have your kind of fix you're going to
have your kind of rewards kind of be
kind of like close to zero or kind of
like plateau to begin with and the kind
of variance and noise issue in
reinforcement learning is kind of very
high so here's an example on the VGO
environment and so I encourage you to
kind of get it if you can so if you're a
student and then you can have it
you can kind of download it for free and
it's compatible with opening a gym and
so I think for this particular
environment they used an algorithm
called normalize advantage functions and
it kind of dropped into a kind of
suboptimal policy so and when you were
in a suboptimal policy like that it's
kind of very difficult to get out of it
because you're in a high you're in a
relatively high reward region so some
kind of research areas ongoing or kind
of multi-agent reinforcement learning
model-based reinforcement learning and
so multi-agent reinforcement learning is
when you've got lots of different agents
and it could be kind of cooperating or
vying for some goal and it's quite
challenging because you're not working
you're not really working in MD you're
not really working because you're your
environment is kind of dynamic and so
you can't use for example your replay
buffer you can't use the States and
actually as you used before because
you're kind of environment is kind of
being it's kind of it's turned very kind
of dynamic because of the introduction
of other agents so model-based RL is
another area where you kind of what
you're learning about your model so for
example you could be learning the
transition dynamics and sometimes that
can really kind of boost your
performance a metro RL which is about
kind of learning to reinforcement man
representation learning and kind of
effective exploration techniques
imitation learning and so an inverse RL
so kind of given a policy can you kind
of reverse engineer what the rewards in
the vironment should be like transfer
learning
and okay so I just kind of like to end
this off with a kind of a nice walk
around it's why Alex Earp an we works in
Google brain so several times now I've
seen people get lured by recent work
they try deep reinforcement any for the
first time and without fail they
underestimate the perils difficulties
without fail the toy problem is not as
easy as it looks and the fuel destroys
them a few times until they set
realistic expectations so thanks for
listening duster end of my talk
[Applause]